cleaning up after a massive storm
flooded this area in the city of La
platin Buenos Aires
Maria Rodriguez is trying to salvage
anything she can but the water destroyed
her refrigerator and the television
I woke up at night and saw all the water
coming in my son sleeps on the floor
because there's nowhere else to sleep we
survive because my mother has a soup
kitchen because otherwise with our
salaries it's impossible
the storm has made the family's dire
living conditions even worse
flooding happens in this part of Buenos
Aires every year people tell us that
they've been promised that the situation
will improve but it doesn't many of
those who live all around this area have
lost all of their belongings and with
the current economic situation in
Argentina and soaring inflation it is
impossible for them to be able to buy it
again
Argentina has been struggling with an
over a hundred percent inflation rate in
the past year it's also trying to pay
back over 40 billion dollars in foreign
debt to the IMF
primary elections last Sunday showed
that Javier melaye a far-right candidate
got around 30 percent of the votes
melee promises radical changes in the
economy
the possibility of him becoming
Argentina's president has shaken up the
presidential race and the economy
the government evaluated the currency
around 18 in an attempt to stop the
outflow of U.S dollars and the prices
started going up once again
the government evaluates when there is a
lack of trust and credibility with very
low reserves and outside of an integral
plan this exacerbates uncertainty and it
won't have a real impact on the economy
so the devaluation translates into more
inflation
and people in Argentina are finding ways
to be financially creative until the end
of the month
Luis Adrian Pereira says the last week
has been impossible
I am angry because those who are
governing are now leaving and all the
prices are going up I had to buy cream
for my foot and it was 800 pesos now
it's 1400 just in a few days
frustration anger and despair are
everywhere as the country gets ready to
elect a new president in two months
many are desperate for solutions that
will give them some sort of stability
back